hey guys and welcome to another episode
of
congratulations
[Music]
off and we're recording and that's it
and the past is the past and here we go
it's congratulations episode whatever it
is i have no idea
uh we've done way too many of them
thought we're only going to do five or
six all good
we're involved we are so involved in the
podcast world it's it's honestly
unbelievable um the king in the wing is
no more
uh sorry the king in the sting is no
more
it is now called
an it is a new show king
and the sting and the wing
so deal with that it's patreon two
episodes and and uh youtube two episodes
each month is four episodes it goes half
and half so you can go over the patreon
patreon.com
catsplus or you can go to the patreon
of our show congratulations either one
do them both you know and you get an
extra episode of congratulations uh just
you know we just keep doubling it you
know that's what we keep doing it that's
the year of doubling it that's what this
year is
2 000 2022 is the year of dublin
um
so yeah we got that if you want to
support the show go to
patreon.comcrystalia
and uh
we added a show in irvine
um it might be sold out by the time this
comes out it's in like a month or so um
so go to chrislea.com i'm also doing a
shorter uh well this i'm doing a spot
over at jam in the van this weekend in
century city in los angeles um go to uh
jamming the van website for that and
then um
i think that's oh phoenix
we're off we gotta fini we got phoenix
april 30th um we are doing i am doing
phoenix crystalia at the celebrity
theater uh saturday april 30th and
tickets are live now pre-sale code
um don't push me in lowercase or if
you're listening to this on friday it's
on the general public so you can just go
to the website go to crystallia.com
it'll figure it all out but you can uh
you can do it but the pre-sale code is
don't push me so if you're in phoenix
and if you are a uh
if you're part of this cult it's your
duty to come out man get that merch on
and let's go um my my thing's not
working okay cool um so yeah so that's
what's up irvine i got a spot coming up
in los angeles and then also phoenix
that's the big one dude that's actually
my i think uh yeah it's my first theater
show uh back after like two two years um
anyway i'm excited for that so uh you
know let's get into it here with the
here with the uh
you know the code is don't push me
because you know how it'd be don't push
me get that merch chrisley.com don't
push me um but i um
yeah i've been having a good week you
know
it's good sometimes just hanging out
with my son it just lets me just kind of
reset realize what the [ __ ] life is all
about
um
kristen brought home a uh
um
what do you call it a [ __ ] like thing
for
just a tchotchke dude i can't believe
kristen and the chochkies honestly if
she's that's like a band from 1950s
from the 50s [ __ ] chris kristen and
the tchotchkes hey we're here here we
are live on the show and we are
introducing a new group kristen and
tchotchkes and it's just her in a short
sparkly [ __ ] dress with tassels on it
and she's just like
gonna be spending your money money she's
gonna be spending your money money
she watches too much videos on youtube
and says we need that and then she goes
to target and all the places and then
she's gonna spend your money money and
then she's gonna spend her money money
all right take it away that's chris
kristen and the tchotchkes
and we go to [ __ ] if she watches one
more thing studio mcgee i'm gonna shoot
my brains out dude
her with the studio mcgee dude it's like
anyone else and [ __ ] nutella
i swear to god
studio first of all it's called studio
mcgee that's like it's a joke you'd make
it's what's her name um
studio mcgee it's shay mcgee is the
girl's name
and she's like the dude she like
straight up like dissed me kristen she's
like i can't believe like your videos
get like millions of views and like
shane mcgee like look at what she gets
it's like not even a million views and
i'm like well what is she doing and
she's just like well look she's like the
most popular um uh
decorator like house interior dick
designer house builder kind of i don't
know she's just a she's a white girl you
know like that's literally any you can
just sum it all up in white with white
girl and she's like just look and it's
beautiful i mean she really has an eye
for this [ __ ] there's a real talent by
the way i'm gonna make fun of her but
it's a real talent so now that i say
it's a real talent off to the race is
with the making fun of him [ __ ]
but her name's shea mcgee and she's like
really popular and she puts like
a whole bunch of creams together and
like won't go as dark as brown but it'll
be like she'll be inching up next to tan
and then as bright as off-white and
that's it dude and it's so calming and
nice and the windows are so open dude
like whole whole like
walls or windows in this [ __ ]
and crystal will be like just look at
this doesn't this make you feel
beautiful this is see this is what i
need that's what she's watching studio
mcgee see this is what i mean just as
the more as kristen's eyeballs watch
studio mcgee
my bank account is just going like this
gonna gonna spend their money money it's
chris get it it's kristin of the josh
and she's gonna spend your money money
and she's gonna spend your money money
she's just gonna buy some cream [ __ ] and
tan [ __ ] she's gonna inch up to ten with
the products products and she's only
gonna buy off white mostly cream no way
she'll buy white or brown
it's just [ __ ] basically tan
different tans and different creams
gonna spend that money money should buy
a dildo if it was cream
she might dildo if it was wooden and
cream and you look good next to a plant
she's gonna spend your money
just [ __ ] she'd buy a [ __ ]
decapitated head if it was just cinching
up the stand
if it was just an introduction i'll
fight it's gonna spin at money money
she buy a [ __ ] swastika if it was
cream
she buy [ __ ] a bunch of swastikas she
could place him around and put him as
coasters she's gonna spin cream
swastikas money money
so studio mcgee is what she's [ __ ]
watching and it's like every video has
900 000 views and it's got white women
all along just like
a white woman turns that [ __ ] on and
they're just like wow see this is see
this see see this is that's what it is
and then the husband's just
oh no bank account just [ __ ]
just gouging the bank oh no so she came
back with like a little wooden [ __ ]
uh wiry bicycle
and now calvin's this is how the [ __ ]
[ __ ] works this is how it works this is
how uh consumerism works so she comes
back with a little bicycles like this
big it's all made out of wire who knows
how much it was however much it was it's
too much all she did is put it on the
island next to a plant and now we got a
little [ __ ] iron bicycle that doesn't
do anything that's just sitting next to
a [ __ ] plant and then calvin looks at
it and he's like oh by tickle particle
and we're like bicycle buy tickle bite
tickle bicycle bite tickle and then
finally bicycle now he won't stop saying
bicycle now we have to take the [ __ ]
thing off of the of the island and now
he's running around with this bicycle
and then if the [ __ ] bicycle breaks
so now it's broken dude and they're
gonna take that money money you got a
[ __ ] [ __ ] cream bicycle and now
it's [ __ ] broken and now guess what
now your son wants a [ __ ] actual
bicycle
now my son wants a bicycle so now we're
looking up other youtube videos of
purchasing my fir my son's first bike
and now this kid's like i want an orange
bike now calvin's like orange bike
orange bike orange bicycle orange bike
my son wants a [ __ ] orange bike so
now i don't need to have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] studio mcgee little mini
bicycle that's wire that's broken that
isn't even by the way it it still is not
it was nothing and it is nothing
it was nothing next to the plant now
that it's broken it just
exposes how nothing it is
you can fix it
still nothing
okay and now my son wants an orange bike
which is fine i want to give my son an
orange bike but it's like you know
it's just like my face with a [ __ ]
graph just going down with my money she
gonna spend that money now she got
calvin involved she got kevin involved
and it's just like jesus now i gotta buy
so
everything's cream in my goddamn house
the only thing that's not cream in my
house because of studio mcgee is [ __ ]
the floor because it's the floor and
it's brown and you can and we're moving
out we're building a house oh my god
dude you know we're building a house
because you know that that's how it goes
because you're a listener of
congratulations if you think
i'm not gonna have the [ __ ] most
cream house of all time you're out of
your [ __ ] mind dude
dude
you guys won't come over but i'll tell
you right now if you're my friend
listening to this dude you're gonna come
over my house is gonna be so
[ __ ] a cream it's gonna look like
milky diarrhea dude i'm gonna have the
milkiest diarrhea
the most milkiest diarrhea in this house
of all time it's only gonna be cream
dude you're gonna see my house gonna be
like did a giant crap all over it and on
the inside too
it's childish gonna be 42. but that's
the truth dude
i can't believe how cream everything on
[ __ ] studio mcgee is [ __ ] yeah dude
i'm relatable i don't give a [ __ ] this
is my deal here this is my deal here
milky diarrhea house
what is it with [ __ ] cream and white
chicks dude for real
for real
remember when chicks just like pink
and then machine gun kelly [ __ ] it all
up
if i see another [ __ ] machine
when's the last time you seen it machine
gun kelly an outfit that didn't have
pink all over it
also i like machine gun kelly i'm a fan
of i met him once and he was nice as
[ __ ] i don't know one thing of his songs
and that's fine dude i don't think it's
for me but that [ __ ] dude i like
guys who are like who got like people
saying like [ __ ] that guy about him i
like that guy but he's a tall [ __ ]
strinky pale drink of water right but
he's wearing pink dude if you're pale
you're not supposed to wear pink he
knows it and he doesn't carry he doubles
down fine but dude remember when chicks
on pink
and now you got the most the the machine
gun kelly's of the world were in pink
and you've got the white chicks on this
cream train
it's fine right there's other things to
be worried about like what's happening
in ukraine but this is my [ __ ] thing
dude if you want to look if you want to
learn about the ukraine and russia go to
npr man but we don't stand for that and
i hear
ours is about chilling talking about the
minor issues that are in fact the major
issues okay because you can't change the
world unless you start with the minor
[ __ ]
everyone's always like we want [ __ ]
we want the homeless we want the
homeless uh uh to be able to have houses
and we want
you know uh uh no hunger and [ __ ]
peace bro are you kidding me you gotta
start
with the [ __ ] cream dude you gotta
start with expanding white chicks minds
with different colors and i'm just
saying
and it's fine what's happening over in
ukraine is an absolute travesty
obviously do i know anything about it no
i have one friend that's pro putin and
it's really [ __ ] weird it's really
odd that he's pro-putin i don't know
anything about it all i know is if you
were to like come out on social media
about supporting putin you'd lose all
your [ __ ] jobs that's all i know and
my buddy is really secretly into putin
and it's very weird and i've gotta
[ __ ] figure out what the hell's going
on so i know if i could you know
but it is what it is
patreon.com crystalia um it is what it
is dude
i you know i'm a
i'm uh i don't know i don't i don't
think
you know i just don't i'm not
look i can just come out and say some
basic [ __ ] like war isn't the answer and
i don't think war is the answer right
because it's like
i don't know it's guys with their egos
and [ __ ] and it's like
if you were gonna be a [ __ ] i think i
was one parent away from being a [ __ ]
warlord or a dictator for real and i'm
not joking which is one parent away i
don't even know which one but if i if
you mixed one parent one of my parents
up with another parent
just with the way they are instant
warlord
i've always you know i've said that
um
so yeah i don't know what's going on in
the world though i try to stop i don't
want to listen to the news i know it's
like be educated and [ __ ] i was talking
to my therapist about this earlier but i
was like dude i can't stand when these
[ __ ] actors are just like out there
like we need to stop what's happening in
ukraine and you're like oh really dude
oh really
oh yeah
oh oh is that what we're supposed to do
[ __ ] uh
you know fourth lead in yellowjackets
or whatever the [ __ ] that show is on hbo
oh yeah is that what we're supposed to
do
you're posting the ukrainian flag oh
yeah
thanks
thanks third lead in super pumped
[Laughter]
all right yeah thanks [ __ ] you know
that [ __ ] show super pumped
you know i had to check it out because
just jason gordon levitt's in it
you know i had to check that [ __ ] out
because joseph joseph levitt [ __ ]
whatever his name have two names dude
you know have two names
if you [ __ ] want somebody to do like
joseph gordon-levitt
you're a you're a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
sucker you know that right
like you're a [ __ ] straight up like
if you're a guy that's just like oh i'm
actually like thomas hayden church
how first of all he [ __ ] it up
tom church is the illest name dude
why would you want to
if your last name is church why would
you want to spend the extra time saying
your middle name when you could get
right to church dude
if my if my i'm telling you right now
dude if my second name if my last name
was church
oh dude well first of all i would have
never got cancelled
i would be literally fro i'll probably
be one of the top comics
chris church i mean i am one of the top
comics but i probably would be one of
the even more tapas comics chris church
dude tom church is the [ __ ] and this
guy's trying to [ __ ] space it out
with hayden that's that's crazy to me
honestly that's why thomas hayden church
biggest role was either sideways or the
sandman in one of the spider movies if
it wasn't he would be the rock
um so i watched uh fear thy neighbor
which is another show
that's just creepy where like you gotta
dude i watch the show fear thy neighbor
and it's like one of those shows that
like ins that like you find like we we
signed up for discovery plus
and like it's just one of those shows
that that you are like huh what's this
it shows like half a person's body on
the [ __ ]
on the icon and it just just fear thy
neighbor like it's cut into the into
wood
and it's like so bad it's probably
wanted to watch it because it's so beige
the [ __ ] the
the icon for it is so beige it's like it
was made by studio mcgee fear thy
neighbor studio mcgee
and uh
so we we click it and it's one of those
shows that like they're oh there's just
11 seasons of it you know how where the
[ __ ] do these shows get off being 12
years old already
you know i'm talking about
like
how do i not know a show this is the
state right now of the entertainment
industry
the fact that i don't know a show
that i can possibly not know what a show
is
or that it exists and it's already in
season 12.
how is it beyond season four and i don't
and i don't know about it
there's just too many shows out there so
we put on sphere the neighbor and we
start watching it
and it's like about these awful
neighbors that just lose their mind and
there's [ __ ] literally let's see so
it's six episodes in season one i don't
know there's probably more episodes in
the next season so let's just do the
math so six times 11 seasons so that's
66 there's at least 66 shows which means
there's different episodes of neighbors
losing their mind and on this show it's
not just the neighbors losing their
minds it's the neighbors
goading the people who live there to
lose their minds their self so that's
doubling it so it's 66 times two so
that's what uh 112 right isn't that what
66 times 2 is your boy's real good at
math isn't he is it is that even what it
is 66 times 2 hey series what's 66 times
2
hey siri what's 66 times 2
hey siri what's 60 [ __ ]
132. whoa he was so close
[ __ ] yeah dude he couldn't have been
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
closer what do you say 112 it doesn't
matter math was never a strong suit but
he [ __ ] yeah he's got the gift of god
no nothing oh god
and is that what gets you further on in
life yeah
he got a d [ __ ] he got a d plus in
algebra two but my god he got that thing
[Music]
but did he get a [ __ ] back rated
english yeah he did too as a matter of
fact
but did he create his own way of
speaking yeah
and then he's got people behind him he's
got an army behind him with [ __ ]
people understand what he's saying yeah
he does
so anyway dude
so now we're watching feel the neighbor
so it's doubling it so it's 66 times two
that's what is it 132 132 so now what my
point is it's not that just just the
neighbor that's crazy it's the person
that lives there that's crazy so that's
132 crazy people through the span of
this show now those are just the ones
that they pick for the best episodes and
guess what happens in the best episodes
one of the neighbors kills the other one
okay
so these are the most extreme some of
these episodes a few people end up dying
so these are the most extreme versions
of the craziest people that are
neighbors in the world okay so my thing
is
if people like this are so crazy and
they're just out there being neighbors
and
132 of them are in a show about it
how many are there in real life number
one and number two let's just jump right
to it how can you ever trust anything
anyone says
in history
i'm just gonna meet someone and believe
them dude these people meet it starts
off nice as [ __ ] these shows
these shows are just like tom was there
and he moved in and he noticed that
there was something weird and a dog came
by and [ __ ] peed on his fence and and
then there was a broken bottle so the
other guy got really mad and he started
teaching his kids how to how to [ __ ]
march like an army outside of the house
with guns in their hands and you're like
whoa whoa wait a second it started nice
so how could you believe anything anyone
ever says dude if there's not so
neighbors out there these are just
neighbors again
they're not people in the military that
have like scarred [ __ ] you know
like a guy with a scarred past that like
liam neeson would play
right
these are all [ __ ] insane people that
you don't know about it they're over
undercover insane so the other thing is
why are we listening to anybody on the
internet
and this is the main point i wanted to
drive home because
if you're meeting people that are
neighbors and they're two-faced or you
don't know their mental capacity or how
broken their brain is
then how can you trust somebody you
don't know that you meet and then beyond
that how can you trust somebody behind a
keyboard that might not even be the
person who's tweeting they might be
someone else and we'll just go along
with it
the guy from jeopardy doesn't have a job
anymore
these people are all your [ __ ] crazy
neighbors
fear thy neighbor dude fear thy everyone
just [ __ ] hole up love your family
right
i don't know man i want to not trust
people like i want to do a little bit
more like tupac you know in my own life
i want to be a little bit more like
[ __ ] you know what i mean
[ __ ]
but like i'm not that guy i can't i'm
not you know i want to be [ __ ] tupac
so bad you know what i mean like
[ __ ] your [ __ ] i'm so kind of i want to
you know i want to get that thug life
tatted across my belly you know what i
mean i want to be like [ __ ] your [ __ ]
but i'm like too nice you know i really
am my son changed me dude and not that i
was ever [ __ ] tupac like [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ]
but like i am now
even softer than i've ever been
and i want to not trust people but then
i meet them and they look me in the eyes
and i smile at them and then i realize
that you know yeah my smile is a little
bit intoxicating
and theirs might be disarming but guess
what i'm right there too and my smile's
disarming as well so now we're both
unarmed just intoxicating the [ __ ] out
of each other
and i hope that you're not [ __ ] gonna
have a broken brain and i'm gonna figure
it out too late with a knife in my belly
be careful out there that's all i'm
saying man
i did get a [ __ ] d in algebra though
and like a c in english
when i was in high school but who cares
[Music]
all right listen up you guys i want to
talk to you about a little thing i like
to call ship station and the reason why
i like to call it that is because it's
called that online shopping isn't
slowing down anytime soon of course it
ramps up and up and up and up is your
business ready to keep up the pace
that's the big question well with
shipstation you'll never worry about
shipping again make the switch to a
solution that handles all of your
shipping needs
quickly affordably and painless
shipstation is already trusted by over
100 000 ecommerce sellers all right keep
track of orders from any sales channel
easily find the best shipping carrier
with deeply discounted rates automate
just about any shipping task with just a
few clicks
my favorite thing about shipstation is
for me crystallia all uh of the fans
like happily getting their orders and
getting them quickly
fast
with like it's like hassle-free it's
just the best i use ship station so uh
you should too man um you save time by
funneling all of your orders into one
simple interface no matter what you're
selling or where you're selling manage
every order amazon ebay etsy or even
your own website uh from anywhere even
your phone everyone's doing everything
on their phone lately you save money
also when you uh you can compare the
carrier options and choose the best
shipping solution every single time uh
and honestly the best thing the biggest
thing for me is save your sanity
because you can know your orders are
handled and you're getting the best
rates that's what shipstation does uh
gives you the best rates so make
shipping the easy part of having an
online store it's already stressful
enough you have bigger ideas to think
about and handle 98 of companies that
use shipstation for a year keep using it
for as long as they're in business case
close it's that good
ship more in less time with shipstation
use my offer code okay the offer code is
congrats to get a 60 day free trial
that's two months free
two months free no hassle stress free
shipping just like i said all of the
things above
just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at
the top of the page and type in congrats
ship station make ship happen
yo what's up want to talk to you a
little bit about these things called
blenders man check out these sunglasses
what the heck why are they so
ridiculously cool it's not just cause
i'm wearing them dude i love them but
they're called blenders eyewear and they
got tons of styles and colors for their
sunnies whether you want a sleek all
black look to be understated or to stand
out with bright colors and wrap around
lenses they got it all the quality is
second to none every pair is built to
last with incredible attention to detail
and almost all sunglasses come polarized
you know how cool they are check them
out
i love them because uh i got a few of
them and when i'm in party mode i could
just rock around and just be be out and
just be kind of cool with them and
people be like what are those sunglasses
and i'm like
blenders
um
they have more than just sunnies there's
prescription sunglasses and eyeglasses
blue light glasses
and even snow goggles and
yo they have helmets so go check it out
uh is a 45 day satisfaction guarantee
get 15 off by going to
blenderseyeware.com
and using the code chris dalia vip
these sunglasses are awesome got them in
my car got them in my house got him
everywhere and i just throw him on
and immediately i'm in party mode
[Music]
i'm just like it's a shame that we have
to deal with other people's crazinesses
like i've got a but like everyone has
their own [ __ ] you know everyone has
their own [ __ ] but like my buddy
uh oh first of all i went to [ __ ] i
went to a diner the other night and i'll
get into my buddy being crazy but i went
to a diner the other night and my
[ __ ] dude remember how i do remember
how i said i had rat damage in the
[ __ ] in my one car and then i had the
i had to get a whole new uh
system computer system in one car and i
took that car back and then i got that
other car and then that car said they
said they had rat damage but then they
didn't have rat damage i said in the
with chris video the last one the
chick-fil-a one that the [ __ ] that
the rat that i that they said i had rat
damage in my audi but i didn't have rat
damage they sent me the bill and it was
zero [ __ ] dollars dude they sent me
the bill i get a i get a text from audi
here's your bill and i was like bill
they never even told me what it was and
they're already delivering the car and i
didn't pay for it i clicked on the [ __ ]
and it said zero dollars
why had texted me something like this
first of all and just give me the
[ __ ] car
and and what did you do to it they
didn't even tell me they were just like
yeah we fixed it and then i looked at it
was like uh it was literally like
transistor clicker thing fix in like
manual labor what did they do dude and
now the air conditioning works and so
now i got all my cars working and guess
what happens i take it to a diner i take
my [ __ ] i take i take my car with the
[ __ ] bloody insides i take it to the
[ __ ] diner dude and of course i'm
[ __ ] doing it and then you know yeah
i got [ __ ] bloody guts on the inside
right i mean it looks real nice it looks
like a friend opened up your anus and
you stuck your head in there right i
mean it's really pink and super nice
right it's so pink mgk should be wearing
it on [ __ ] ellen i mean it's real
nice but nobody could tell because the
windows are too thin
right no but it's pink inside they say
but is that a [ __ ] mystery or what
because we can't see in it the windows
are rolled up because he doesn't want
him to see his face because he's a
celebrity
but he's got two chains now but how do
we know he might as well be rolling up
two brick walls on the outside of his
creme de la creme mercedes
why because we can't see him
well quick hop on a bird because the
roof's exposed oh god
what's that mean if you get on a
pterodactyl you can look down and see
the bloody guts
oh
and so it goes
and so it goes
[Laughter]
well we can see the mango white but you
said it
the windows are up
but the dual exhaust and the yadda yadda
and the black plates and the sure yeah
but um
but you said the inside is a whole
goddamn computer screen and the seats go
back and you can basically take a nap
but yeah
so i pull up to the [ __ ] diner i eat
the diner i get what i get you know how
daddy does it with the [ __ ] chicken
sandwich god damn it that's just
chef's kiss not gonna tell you where it
is because i want to go again and i
don't want you there
but god damn it the chicken [ __ ]
sandwich at this point oh god chef's
kiss right
i mean this chicken sandwich oh my
[ __ ] god and guess what it's under
new ownership because the [ __ ]
pandemic ruined everything and the
and the diner went down and got sold to
different people and they didn't really
change the menu except they changed
their fries and guess what dude when
you're gonna change something that's
[ __ ] awesome it always gets worse but
the fries are [ __ ] better
so i'm sitting there eating chicken
sandwich with the fries and you know i
keep it lean right johnny keeps it real
lean like i'm so lean dude i should be
in the [ __ ] show twilight but i'm not
though because i'm pale too but i'm not
though right
so i eat i eat the chicken sandwich you
know i don't even get a brownie because
your boy's [ __ ] i'm sorry strong guys
but i've been looking real [ __ ] you
know it's like i'm real where i need to
be and i got mountains where it needs to
be okay
i mean the [ __ ] boulders on my back
are absolutely unfucking they're
unbelievable but also my waist it's trim
right
so i eat this [ __ ] i go out
and
oh wow this is [ __ ] funny well
actually let me talk to you about how
crazy my friend is a little bit after
this because i even got more story
coming see this is what happens i start
one thing and i [ __ ] you know we get
rolling and rolling and then this turns
into another thing and that's why every
[ __ ] podcast is two stories
so um
so i'm in swingers
that's the place i go to i've exposed it
i don't care go if you want to sometimes
i go i don't normally go but every now
and then i go and i'm eating the chicken
sandwich i want to shout them out
because chef's kiss okay i want to shout
them out because they [ __ ] went under
new management and guess what thought
the fries were going to suck but the
fries are even better now chef's kiss
okay now that's fine but i'm eating
[ __ ] chicken sandwich chef's kiss and
the fries chef's kiss all right now i'm
doing that and then i go and i leave and
i get in my car yes i'm all [ __ ] you
know
i'm inside the [ __ ]
uh right the bloody guts and i get home
all's well that ends well
i get in my bed
you know probably argue about what tv
show we're gonna watch a little bit with
krista and then i go to sleep
and i wake up the next morning had an
awful night's sleep and i remember this
because i went back to sleep after i ate
breakfast i cooked breakfast for me and
calvin and we ate right
like father and son and we had a good
time and then i went to sleep at 11 30
again okay
i went to sleep at 11 30 again and then
i wake up to kristen saying chris and
immediately the tone in her voice
my heart
my heart's gonna explode okay
because i've had a rough two years and
when somebody comes up and says hey hey
chris hey chris in the dead of sleep
my heart's gonna blow up right
so i wake up out of this deep sleep and
my heart's pumping so i say what's up
and she says um okay i don't know but
like i don't know when this happened but
the back passenger window of your car is
completely shattered like somebody was
trying to break in
so now i realize it's okay to be anxious
because what the [ __ ] happened last
night okay
so
i go outside and as clear as day i mean
my [ __ ] window in the back right is
just splintered as all get out and
somebody tried to either take a rock or
a screwdriver and puncture it 19 times i
counted 19 times dude
we did it because i've got a [ __ ]
nanny that's a real real like sleuth
like that's why she also likes to watch
the [ __ ] like feel the neighbor because
she's a real sleuth she'll be like well
it was punctured 19 times and it looked
like it was done by a professional but i
don't think they were actually trying to
steal your car because why would they
try to do it in the back left window
when they when when when if you're going
to try to steal a car you just go to the
closest window and that's the driver's
side you just crawl in and then drive
away and i was like aha very good but
why did they come down here and try to
steal something while i was sleeping at
night in my house
so i got really nervous because la
is a [ __ ] dumpster fire right now you
know that
because of how you can just rob a car
and they'll let you
okay
so
now i'm like well [ __ ] man these who
ever gonna do they're gonna come again
because right because you hear that
thing where it's like oh the banks that
gets that get robbed they get robbed
again so i'm like well [ __ ] now they're
gonna try to come for my car tonight so
guess what your boy did your boy doesn't
[ __ ] around i hired armed security dude
i hired armed
security they showed up this dude looked
like a ball player he was just like
what's up
i got armed security
outside of my house like i'm the goddamn
president
so i hired armed security
and
as the night fades
i go outside and i look at the
i look at the car
and i can't see really the splintering
so i find that odd
and so kristin was like well if you
couldn't see it then maybe it happened
while you were at swingers the other
night and i go
yeah that makes much more sense
it happened when i was at swingers
because at night when i walked back from
swingers i couldn't see the [ __ ]
window being splintered and it didn't
happen at my house because why the [ __ ]
would it happen at my house if it was
gonna happen on my house it would be the
front window and somebody would try to
steal the car and they wouldn't give up
it was probably just a crazy person
walking on beverly boulevard that
[ __ ] said some [ __ ] like science is
everywhere and then bashed my window in
and i was like there we go maybe they
just heard about the bloody guts and
they wanted to see it for their own man
you know what i mean i don't know
so
uh
i had two nights of the armed security
and it's nice to know i can get arm
security when i want to the guy was
bawling though the guy was cool as [ __ ]
he was like what's up sir i'm here he
had a gun and he was ready and i invited
my friends over and i was like oh [ __ ] i
should go tell them i said hey by the
way i have two friends coming over
they're not robbing me you're like okay
good i'm glad you let me know i'm like
oh why were you gonna shoot them
anyway
so
now i got a [ __ ] car problem again
dude rats ate my wires and rats ate my
wires and [ __ ]
two flat tires
and
someone hit my other car and now i got
[ __ ] i got many car problems but
maybe it's because i have many cars oh
god
whatever dude my point is it's crazy out
there in los angeles but what happened
was
now i'm at swingers
and this is what i wanted to tell you
about how crazy my friend is
i don't know what's up with my friend
maybe he's on the spectrum i don't
really know and i don't mean to knock
anybody on the spectrum i actually think
maybe my friend is on the spectrum but
he like
i don't know he does this thing where
like we were we were in the place
swingers and [ __ ] there's a dog in
the restaurant
and it's on a leash and i notice it
because it's a dog in a restaurant
and i'm like okay maybe it's like a
[ __ ]
either a seeing eye dog and nobody's
blind there though so i'm like okay it's
an emotional support
pet but i'm like
leave him at home right there's food
i'm like isn't this unsanitary how'd
this person get this [ __ ] dog in a
diner have you ever seen a dog in a
diner i've never seen a dog in a diner i
know i'm looking down to my right as i'm
paying and there's a dog in a diner
now what do i not want to do i don't
want to give this person any [ __ ]
energy because they've got a dog and a
diner and anyone with a dog in a diner
what do they want they want one thing
energy
and that could be in the form of
attention it could be in the form of
anger it could be the form of anything
but they want looks they want something
they want energy so i don't [ __ ] give
it to him because it's all out war when
you got a dog in the diner and i'm there
you want that attention you want that
energy well guess what troops mobilize
no
i got those binders on
i'm not looking at you if you've got a
dog in an under but i notice that the
peripheral like a hippo
okay
and then i notice more out of my
peripheral
my friend
with his phone out
taking a picture of the dong
he's taking a picture of it
this is exactly what they [ __ ] wanted
you know
i'm so annoyed
i'm just like oh great in the meantime i
don't know this but somebody's literally
trying to break into my [ __ ]
[ __ ] car i have no idea but
that's beside the point
so he's trying to [ __ ] god damn take
a picture of this and i look at him and
i just see his [ __ ] smile and i hear
it you know it's one of those [ __ ]
hearing you can hear you know how some
people's faces you can just hear if
you're close enough like newscasters
theo vaughn's like that too but my
buddy's like that and he's taking a
picture and i hear his [ __ ] face just
from being close to it and out of the
peripheral in my [ __ ] i see the
[ __ ] guy taking a picture and i go
why are you taking a picture of this dog
and he says
i don't know
and now i'm pissed off more because he
doesn't even have a [ __ ] reason so
he's just taking a picture of the dog
so now he takes a picture of the dog i
finish paying
and i walk outside
with him
oh i forgot another part of the thing a
guy this is why la's going [ __ ] to
hell in a hand basket so as we're eating
the food
okay
a homeless guy walks into the diner with
[ __ ] all over him oh i forgot the best
part oh oopsie daisy the story was so
banging that i forgot the best part as
if it was the worst part
so this homeless guy walks in with
excrement on him not like hey bro you
got [ __ ] on you and it's not [ __ ] like
hey bro you have [ __ ] on you and it's
excrement and guess where it is the
worst possible place where chris his
mouth nope his hands
oh but that's not worse than i thought
let me stop you right there
it's worse to have [ __ ] on your mouth if
it's yours
if it's someone else it's bad when it's
on their hands cause they can touch you
okay so hey guy i don't mean to be rude
to you i feel bad that you're down and
out but you got [ __ ] on your hands so
you've got to get out of the
establishment that i'm in
so the [ __ ] dude came over like the
dude who was the manager he's like hey
man you just gotta go you gotta go you
know you gotta go and the guy was like
yeah but i need some money and he was
like yeah but you gotta go and he's like
can i just have a dollar to somebody
else in another booth it's like you
gotta go you got [ __ ] on your hands you
gotta go you got [ __ ] on your hands
and the guy just [ __ ] wafted it all
up so i was like [ __ ] right
the guy ends up leaving
so then we pay and my buddy takes a
picture with the dog sorry i'm doing an
ad order like i'm quitting tarantino or
something but i'm telling a story and
this is how it goes right
so as we're leaving
i say to him
man what a weird night
and he says
why just because i took a picture of a
dog
and as we're walking out i say nah man
cause of the guy who had [ __ ] all over
his hands
not the people who had a dog at the
diner and as i'm walking out there's a
[ __ ]
gay couple
with a [ __ ] dog eating outside on the
patio and they're right next to me
and the guy says to me
well yeah we're in la and i say oh [ __ ]
now i'm in this predicament
i wasn't talking about this guy and also
here's the thing i don't care if the
dog's outside of the diner and you're on
the patio that's where it should be but
this guy now thinks that i'm bitching
about him being outside on the patio
with the dog at the diner and he says oh
and i said no no i'm actually it
actually has nothing to do with you what
i'm saying and he says okay because i
was gonna say well that was
extraordinarily sarcastic and i was like
i know i get it but it really wasn't and
i say look at that cutie because the dog
was cute and as i'm saying look at that
cutie
my buddy who i think might perhaps be on
the spectrum is taking another picture
of this goddamn dog
so now
i'm fuming dude
can i just get out of this goddamn diner
without making a documentary about dogs
excuse me but am i a pa on a documentary
about dogs and diners
or am i just chilling with my weird
friend that just happens to take
pictures of [ __ ] dogs and diners
because either way
i don't want to be a part of it
whoopsie daisy i've either got this job
as a documentarian
or i'm hanging out with this friend
who's taking pictures of dogs for no
reason
so i begin to walk away because not only
do i want to distance myself from my
friend
i don't even want to be in this
situation at all
so i'm like if you're going to take a
[ __ ] picture of this dog after not
learning your lesson on the first one
then dude you're on your [ __ ] own
so as i'm walking away the guys are like
oh wow and my buddy of all he's taking
the picture of the [ __ ] dog and he's
trying to get the dog's attention and
the guys are like sitting there like
posing
this poor gay couple just sitting there
just posing like what's this [ __ ]
weirdo dude doing my buddy trying to get
the dog attention he goes like this
and the dog
loses
his
mind i mean dude don't hey number one
hey let's make a list of things to not
do when you see a random dog
number one
stab him
number two snap at him
because you don't know what the dogs are
doing this dog goes
and the gay dude's like oh okay okay
and my buddies taking pictures they're
all coming out blurry like the dogs in
the [ __ ] ring
like it saw the video and then
and so then my buddy just like a [ __ ]
just walking over to me
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] bro
what was all that and he was like yeah
the [ __ ] on his hands and i'm like i'm
talking about the [ __ ] dogs now
and we get in my car bloody guts we
don't see the [ __ ] splintered
this is the when it happened right that
somebody tried to break in my car i mean
what a [ __ ] travesty this whole night
so i get in the car we're both sitting
in the [ __ ] bloody guts and i say to
him i say hey man
i gotta know sorry this is just
something for me just for me my
well-being you did your [ __ ] now let me
just do mine right it's like a
conversation where you let somebody talk
you do the listening now it's my turn
okay
you got to do all your [ __ ] by taking
the pictures of the dogs
and all your misunderstanding about the
guy with the [ __ ] on his hands and now
it's [ __ ] my turn okay we're in my
car i'm in the driver's seat
literally
so i say
why did you why did you take that
picture of that dog in the inside
and he says
well no but i i thought it i because i
thought it was cute and i said no no no
i get wanting to see the dog and i
understand why you did it in that way
but why did you take the picture and he
said i thought it was cute and i said no
no no i thought the dog was cute as well
but why did you take that picture and he
said
i don't know i guess i wanted to have
the picture and then i said
why
and then he said i guess i don't know i
could
look at it whenever i want to
and i said
you're never gonna look at that photo
again
and he started laughing and he said i
don't know maybe i'll post it on
instagram and i said yeah and what are
you gonna say
he said i'll probably put on my story
and i'll i'll put like
i don't know swinger's diner
[Music]
not worth it
[Music]
worth it population zero
i mean dude
oh yeah
you're gonna post a picture of a dog
cool man
well you got it
you got that picture
and then we walked outside
and you took another picture
of a dog
hey man
why'd you do that one
and he said well cause i thought the dog
looked cute and i said no no no we've
already been down this road
why
and he said
well i thought it would be funny
if i posted a picture of a dog and then
i posted another picture of a dog
it would be like what's up with all
these dogs
because this is lost
because it doesn't make sense
because that's what they do in the show
lost
during commercial break
it'll go
so now we're doing it now
because this situation makes as much
sense
as the show lost
when my friend takes one picture of a
dog
but one my friend takes two pictures of
two dogs
i just do don't understand this
like also you're just you're just like
in your 40s uh you know what i mean
who you [ __ ] steve irwin
pick a brand you know pick a lane
oh now you're a guy who takes pictures
of dogs at a diner
for [ __ ] sake
i i mean i like a [ __ ] it's like dude
i deal with that craziness
because he's my friend and i love him
he's one of my best friends in the world
and i love him taking pictures of dogs
or not but that's a down-ass
[ __ ] and i know his craziness
but my point is there's new people you
meet and those people are [ __ ]
absolutely bonkers crazy those people
maybe are the people that bring the dogs
in the diner or even worse maybe they're
the person who walks into a diner with
[ __ ] all over his hands
you don't know people
but you know your friends
so stay tight with your friends and try
not to meet too many people
and definitely don't listen to anybody
there's always a moral
right
there's always a moral
and the moral is
you know
don't watch super pumped
i do love this podcast
and uh
let's watch this rick ross video i mean
is this guy [ __ ] a fan of the podcast
or what dude this guy's an insane
[ __ ] person while i'm watching this
one dude one fire will you look up the
[ __ ] expensive sweat one because he
did that one too i don't even know if
you heard about it
so rick ross bringing down a cow here
this is rick ross doing it getting on a
camel
so [ __ ] immediate [ __ ]
oh cincy
the end of it dude dude someone
screenshot that face
so worried half on
it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh
face at the end dude cincy you know what
the thing is about rappers honestly
they're like batman
they can't do [ __ ] that might leave them
cincy right like imagine batman
was a real person don't have people with
[ __ ] iphones film you getting on a
camel you're gonna look so [ __ ] unless
you do it all the time
you gotta remain at the utmost most
hardcore [ __ ] of all time you can't all
you can't be rapping about rims hoes and
money and how you kill people and how
you're about and then all of a sudden
you want to [ __ ] just jump on a camel
you might fall and be sabich and upsy
daisy rick ross you were and now we lose
respect
what's happening to all these
[ __ ]
they used to be the [ __ ] and now nobody
even cares about being the [ __ ]
these [ __ ] were
rappers were just killing it dude and
now they got to do all extra [ __ ] like
[ __ ] dj khaled getting on a jet ski
and being like
you know
boss
i got a camel that rides itself
this tick tock message to putin really
kind of brings it home
you know honestly this is the thing
about the the
i think if putin just saw this we could
figure it out
here we go
hey britain stop
good point
hey pretend stop please good
please stop
just learned it
i think he's talking about poutine
hey putin stop
imagine if he just ate a bunch of
poutine and [ __ ] himself and this is
what he's talking about poutine
that's literally what's happening
wow dude
hey britain hey putin stop
well that's funny if you watch that
video and think about what i said well
i'm good i'm good
dude these people like
i don't know
i went to the coffee bean with calvin
and it was just so nice man
you know
i talk a lot of [ __ ] and i let stuff get
to me and then
it's so nice to just be a dad and love
that boy so [ __ ] much
like just if i'm real with you
like i was at the coffee bean with him
and i was with two other friends
and they just showed up and it was so
cool man and he was making friends
waving to people i thought i was gonna
have a weird ass pandemic kid that only
knew like 11 people because
of how you know
he didn't meet anybody
for like two years
and now it's just i have this beautiful
kid that we love so much and he's out
there just waving at just
you know nice looking korean ladies and
it's beautiful man
and she says hi what's your name and he
says
tao and she says how old are you and he
says
tu
and you know
and it's all beautiful i got him a hot
chocolate and he was saying hot tucked
it the whole time hot tuck it and then i
said do you i said hi can i get a nice
americana because you know how i do can
i get can i get it dry though and can i
also get a hot chocolate for calvin for
this little boy right here and the lady
said sure do you want it regular
temperature or kid's temperature and
that was when it was hard for me to
fight back tears because i didn't even
know there was a kid's temperature dude
you kidding me you trying to get guys at
cash registers to cry did you try to get
a 41 year old grown man to realize that
his life has changed
just by simply saying
kids temperature
that's a beautiful [ __ ] thing
so i got the kids temperature one and i
put a straw in it because i know it
won't melt even though it's plastic
because it's a kid temperature and so i
gave it to my son and he didn't say hot
even though it was warm because it
wasn't too hot because he says hot about
everything because it was kid's
temperature and he started sucking that
that [ __ ] down and he was drinking it
and he was drinking a lot of it to it
and he loved it man he was going
and then he put it down and he [ __ ]
made friends with the korean lady and it
was beautiful man and then he put his
hands on a little bit of the fire pit
and it was a glass and it was hot he
started crying it was okay dude i held
him i held him through the tears
right but it was a beautiful moment and
then he stopped crying because he
realized it really didn't hurt that much
it was just the glass that was kind of
warm
and they was running all around with the
little [ __ ] dino light up sneakers
i'm so lucky to be that [ __ ] boy's
father man
i'm just so lucky
i couldn't be luckier
and
and he had a jacket that was too big on
you know
you never know what size the [ __ ] kid
is now
you get him what you think and then he
[ __ ] ends up swimming in the goddamn
jacket and you're like okay
you're [ __ ] it's too big but i guess
i'll just keep it on youtube you might
grow into it by the time we're done here
that's the thing about buying clothes
for [ __ ] two-year-olds
you're like oh for [ __ ] sake dude put
it on him now and then tomorrow you take
it off you put it on now take it off and
then tomorrow you put it on him and he's
too big for it
we got too many shoes already that's the
thing if you're going to become a parent
be careful what you buy
because it's going to be [ __ ] not
even
not going to be ready and
it's not going to be able to wear in two
weeks
here's uh david lynch's mess message to
uh putin
if i could say something let me just say
this right now david lynch is my
favorite living director
let's start over if i could say
something to
mr president putin
we are
as human beings
charged
i mean this head of hair that this guy
has is unbelievable dude he's so good i
love [ __ ] david lynch's movies mullen
drive forget it as to how we treat our
fellow man
there is a law
of nature
a hard and fast law
there's no loopholes
there's no escaping it
and this law is
what you sow
you shall reap
reap sober yeah and right now mr putin
you are reaping you are sowing excuse me
you are sowing
death and destruction do it again and
it's all on you
the ukrainians didn't attack your
country
you went in and attacked their country
basically and all this death
and destruction
is gonna come back and visit you
visit and in this big picture this show
that we're involved in
there's an infinite amount of time
so there's plenty of time
life after life after life
for you to reap
what you are sowing
my advice to you is save yourself
save the ukrainians save this world
start getting along with your neighbors
this is what i want calvin to say to a
bully on the playground the whole thing
that would be [ __ ] amazing i gotta
teach him that and have him do that
we're not gonna listen to the rest of it
i'm honestly the my favorite honestly i
think that david lynch probably did some
damage with that speech but honestly
not even close to as much as [ __ ]
this speech and i'm sorry to [ __ ] say
it but this speech bangs a little bit
harder right
good thing things never work when i want
to play them
this is the one that bangs a little
harder
hey britain
stop
stop
put him hey put him stop that one's a
little better
the bang's harder right
marine point you saw
you know in this infinite amount of time
you have a long time to reap
you they have a long time to reap to sew
i mean
you're reap you're sowing right now
but you will be reaping
you know directs some of the most
critically acclaimed and greatest movies
of all time and then reap what you saw
you can sew
you're right now you're excuse me you're
sowing
and then
re you can reap and the thing about it
is
you can there's infinite amount of time
for you to yes you die but
the spirit there is
the natural law that is
reaping what you sow
i i you know what i should just make
another movie he's so good he's so
talented i love him he does so much
transcendental and meditation it's
unbelievable
god what a cool dude he's sexy huh that
guy's sexy
i bet that guy is the [ __ ] ill for
real he's got to be so good at the
horizontal mambo for real like david
lynch absolutely
either that or he doesn't ever he never
has sex just he has like literally
hasn't had sex
in 40 years by design or when he has an
orgasm he goes uh oh
and that's it
and and it's one hard
spurt come and it it feels good for one
hard thing and then that never felt
another pump before you know how [ __ ]
when you bust it out it goes
goes like this
and then later on your your penis is
just a little bit
like it's like falling asleep
his [ __ ] just goes
uh oh
and that's it and then gets limp
uh oh
and then he says and cut
get out
to the woman get out
no he's so nice i bet i guarantee he's
so nice he's so [ __ ] nice
for real get out i have to make a movie
about rabbits you know just a lunatic
oh
thanks for coming by get out i have to
make a movie about rabbits
um
i have to make a movie about maybe a
dream
i think
uh
so that's that i guess you know we had a
good one man
everyone you know i want to be like
everyone should have a kid because my
[ __ ] son changed my life and i love
him so much and he centers me but like i
don't want it to be a selfish thing
either like i don't want it to be like
oh [ __ ] my son changed my life because
it should be all about him sometimes i
do think about that and i and i think
about like oh maybe it's not you know
it's not about me it's about him now so
i try to take myself out of it and just
be there for him and stuff
like he wants to watch [ __ ] like that
bicycle thing i was talking about like
now he wants a bicycle and i just guess
i got to get him a bicycle
well guys that was the episode for
youtube if you want to catch the rest of
the episode the uncut extended episode
go to patreon.com
you can go check it out or you can also
get the uh and you can if you do sign up
for the patreon
patreon.com you also will get uh one
episode one extra episode a month and
all of the backlogged extra episodes so
i think there's like 13 or 14 by now
anyway you also get uh behind the scenes
footage of with chris and just me and my
daily life and then also you have um
review mode which is another segment
that we do but it's all on my patreon go
check it out patreon.comcrystalia
for six bucks and also uh go to
chrisley.com for tickets
uh
phoenix i'm coming and um
new king and the sting of the wing
and the new merch don't push me and the
new oops
merch i [ __ ] forgot to talk about the
oops merch we got oops merch uh that's
new the official oops merch it's on
chrisley.com get it all figured out all
right guys
thanks a lot and take care
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations
congratulations
[Music]
um